live in the lobby of the headquarters of
Ramsey solutions David is with us hi
David how are you great how are you
doing Dave better than I deserve sir
where are you from I'm from Winter
Garden Florida it's a suburb just
outside of our land oh absolutely
beautiful area welcome to Nashville
thank you
so you're here in our lobby to do your
debt-free screen I certainly am that's
awesome how much have you paid officer
about two hundred and fifty two thousand
dollars oh and how long did that take it
was about fifty four months Wow and
range of income during that time between
about 80 up to about 115 okay very cool
very cool
so what kind of debt is the two fifty
two well there was a student loan from
law school in there and my mortgage you
paid off your house and your law school
debt exactly just like that boom fifty
four months so what is that four and a
half years yep wow that's intense it was
I I got a little bit of a boost my
grandparents have given me some mutual
funds when I was younger and that told
it about sixty eight thousand but the
other 184 was just out of my budget each
you know each year just scratching and
clawing exactly okay
cool so you're single I am yeah very
cool so what puts you on this journey
fifty four months ago to decide that you
really could pay off the law school debt
you really could pay off your house well
to kind of give you a little bit of a
background Dave your radio listeners
can't see this but my legs are paralyzed
twelve years ago I fell off the porch
and my legs you know from the waist down
have been paralyzed since then I have a
little bit of strength in my quads so
I'm standing here with a walker in front
of you mm-hmm but after that I figured I
couldn't go into my engineering type
work that I was originally going to do
so I went to law school and racked up
the student loans and a couple years
after that you know I was kind of
muddling along making the minimum
payments had bought a new truck had
bought a house and I looked up and I had
you know two hundred fifty two thousand
dollars in debt mm-hmm and I think I was
driving back one time listening to your
show and I had heard you before but this
was the first time that I really
listened to what you were saying yeah
and you know I realized how much of a
risk that debt was uh-huh and so I got
home that night and started writing
things down in my budget and I
realize that you know I could flow you
know $40,000 a year out of my income and
so you know I previously too that I've
been doing a little bit of everything
you know I was you know doing a 401k and
an IRA and you know obviously saving up
for a truck like I mentioned mm-hmm and
so you know I basically just did exactly
like he taught and focused on one thing
which was the student loan first mm-hmm
and you know I threw a little bit of
that extra money from the mutual funds
like I said at it and threw my money at
it and that was gone within a year and
then I started looking at my mortgage
and you know if I thought well maybe I
could be done by the time I'm 40 and you
know a year later I was looking at being
done by 39 and just this past spring May
13th I did and I was only 37 at the time
I love it very very cool so what kind of
law do you practice
I work in patent law I'm a chemical
engineer undergrad and then law school
one so basically I help people figure
out if their invention is really new or
if somebody came up with it years and
years ago yeah you're really you're
really set up beautifully for that was
both of those degrees absolutely
fabulous that's a very valuable degree
for you then well good for you man
nothing holds you back
well slow and steady you know it was a
lot of work it's is what definitely
wasn't easy you know very cool very cool
well congratulations
so when people find out you've had this
what's this house worth by the way
probably about 230 to 250 somewhere in
that area I love it congratulations that
is so neat so when people found out that
you paid off two hundred fifty two
thousand dollars and fifty four months
and they say how did you do that what do
you tell them the secret to getting out
of debt is I really think the key is
believing that you can do it you know
there's so many people out there who you
know we kind of make mountains out of
mole hills in our minds you know we have
you know my issue obviously I'm disabled
that's not going to change but you know
it doesn't stop me from using my brain
and there's a lot of careers out there
that you know you can get by you know
using your brain rather than using your
body
mm-hm and so you know I found a niche
that I was able to do that you know in
the I did I think one of the things is
that you know no matter how bad our
story is or how many difficulties do you
face there's somebody and there's
probably somebody listening right now
who's been through even more and who's
already been down that path and you know
they've been successful they've gotten
outed
and you know they're retiring now with
dignity and so I think as long as you
know you once you know that somebody has
already made that you know made that
four way into the wilderness and all you
need to do is follow their steps you
know I really think that that's the keys
once you believe you can do it and you
know that somebody's been there before
you know you know that path exists you
know absolutely and that's what these
debt-free screams do they let people
know that you know a guy who fell off
his porch and is standing here with a
walker went back got his law degree and
he cleaned up all that mess with
$100,000 $115,000 income and standing
here literally debt-free you know that's
pretty cool you know that's very
inspiring dude well thank you absolutely
love it very fun you're a hero man this
is fun
very very cool so what was the hardest
part for you I mean four and a half
years how do you avoid like a pity party
in the middle of that I think it's a you
know you've really got to learn to say
no to a lot of things not just friends
and family but society because you know
we're bombarded constantly by
advertisements and you know you go on
Facebook and you see people on vacation
or out to eat or you know new vehicles
and you know you got a you know a
girlfriend telling you oh you should buy
this you can afford it mm and she really
just heard about that kind of girlfriend
yeah she really just means you know that
you can afford the monthly payments you
know and I know that wasn't that wasn't
what I wanted that wasn't the kind of
lifestyle that I wanted you know I
wanted to be debt-free I wanted to you
know have that peace that comes from it
you know and so you know I mean you need
to learn to say no to a lot of things in
your life
absolutely well dude you're you're
impressive man this is fun it's good to
talk to you I'm honored to meet you
we're gonna give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's book Santa retire inspired
signed by him and if I had a copy of
Rachel's I'd give it to you because you
just did a commercial for it lives your
life not theirs when you're saying you
know don't follow the advertisements
don't let other people set your
standards and that's what she's talking
about in that book that's gonna change
so many lives as well so congratulations
thank you all right David from Orlando
250 $2,000 paid off in 54 months making
80 to a hundred and fifteen thousand a
year count it down let's hear a debt
free scream all right three two
1 I'm debt free very well done sir
very well done man that is fabulous
congratulations sir hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common